Kai sanat isn't like most twitch
streamers
his meteoric rise wasn't the random
Confluence of events most streamers
experience on the path to Fame and
Fortune well here we go
[Music]
no kaisenat made a plan and conquered
twitch
attack me on it
oh my God
Kai sanat III was born in New York City
in 2001 and was raised in the Bronx
alongside his twin sister and two
brothers but there was a period after
his parents split up when Kai spent some
time living in a shelter in Georgia
before returning to NYC when I was in
the Bronx is when things started to like
you know feel normal you know I started
to feel like a normal like things
started to feel normal and go a little a
little easier than than usual in middle
school when he was about 13 years old
Kai began uploading short comedic skits
to Facebook before eventually branching
out to Instagram very very disruptive in
class he doesn't do any work he fools
around with his friend he doesn't do any
homework nobody can't say nothing these
ones gonna be mad please feel me
I think no funny [__] I haven't I
haven't shaved
say real quick y'all think I'm lying
look 100
the 70s
I tried 200 trust me I tried 200.
[Music]
but short videos couldn't contain Kai's
massive personality his fans wanted more
so on January 13 2018 Kai uploaded his
first videos to YouTube
hi we're the YouTube channel why don't
you have a YouTube channel you
know I wanted to say
[Music]
he needs some milk oh my God
hold on
oh my God oh my God
wait he's inside
no let's go Kai spent the next few years
making more and more of these videos and
as his side gig became a bigger and
bigger part of his life Kai made the
difficult decision to drop out of
college and commit to content creation
full time
what is wrong with you why are you
dropping out for the cottage videos is
freaking Bankers man the college videos
is what made this channel I'm never
gonna lie the college video is what's
made this channel but let me tell y'all
something man when you know that
something is holding you back from
getting to the next level it's like you
just have to sacrifice that now don't
get me wrong I'm going to miss College
daily for real I'm going to miss College
dare Lee but I just figure I just came
to a realization that it was actually
holding me back in the long run it was
around that time that Kai joined forces
with a YouTube Collective called any
means possible or amp for short and even
though Kai wasn't one of the founding
members the others immediately saw
something special in their newest
edition everybody was telling everybody
like somebody go jump in the pool and
everybody was like nah but he did it
like he did it he went and jumped in the
pool like no hesitation he'll I do it
boom did it and I was like ah like yeah
it was tough because it really showed me
that he had no fears bro Kai already
knew that he was on the path to fame he
wasn't scared of putting himself out
there instead he knew that being the
biggest personality in the room was how
he could make sure his fan base grew
alright in today's video we will be
escaping prison welcome to Fear Factor
where six contestants battle it out over
a span of eight intense challenges these
stunts challenged the contestants both
physically and mentally
as more and more people discovered Kai
either through amp or via his own
YouTube channel he began the next phase
of his plan he started streaming on
Twitch I'm starting to stream on Twitch
tonight's
so make sure you
go which is
in place most people go to try to become
famous on the internet these days but
Kai wasn't like most people he wasn't
starting from scratch his loyal fan base
followed him from YouTube to Twitch and
his first stream was a resounding
success that earned him 1.5 K followers
and well that was a good start over the
next few months Kai blew it out of the
water
hey hey
but conquering streaming's biggest
platform wasn't going to be easy twitch
is loaded with people who on the surface
seems to make the same content Kai did
high energy streams reaction content
playing games it's all pretty standard
on Twitch but Kai sanat was a man with a
plan just the way he attacks things like
he's very clever and smart like behind
the scenes what's going to separate you
from everybody else
is will you keep going or will you just
stop most streamers write Trends find a
comfortable Groove and keep doing what
made them popular in the first place but
Kai wanted to go bigger he ventured into
24-hour sub-a-thons hosting celebrities
on his streams and producing
increasingly elaborate versions of
pranks that made him famous in the first
place
enough
no baby in your mouth
you see how I'm coming oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
oh see how you feel about that
oh you liked it okay oh
I'm so sorry by putting more and more
effort into these planned events Kai's
stream stood out from the pack Kai
collaborated with other streamers each
one helping Propel him further and
further towards his goal and while the
content got more elaborate he never
really stopped being the same guy he was
back when he made those Facebook videos
all those years ago all right he got us
he got us bro he got no he got us bro
let me down let me down he got us he got
us bro Kai was grinding streaming and
making content every day always with one
goal in mind his thing he always told me
he was like man I don't even care about
the money bro he says he cares about
milestones and in October of 2022 Kai
hit that goal he became the number one
most sub 2 streamer on Twitch cementing
him as the most popular personality on
the platform but this is where Kai's
story gets a little complicated you see
twitch has always been slow to
acknowledge his accomplishments a fact
that wasn't lost on other big streamers
Kai was undeniably huge and was also
named streamer of the year at the 2022
streamy Awards my supporters I love
y'all to death of the year is crazy man
I appreciate y'all thank y'all thank
y'all
and yet there was still something about
Kai that kept him on the fringes being
famous comes with haters of course but
twitch wasn't offering him big streaming
contracts his Fame only seemed to matter
to his fans and so Kai set a new goal he
was already the biggest but what if he
could get even
on February 1st 2023 Kai began a
Non-Stop 30-day subathon 3 30 days for
your life well okay
but broken
but sir it is your supperdine oh
[Music]
oh super dancer now Kai wasn't the first
streamer to embark on a quest of
broadcasting his life 24 7 for a month
straight Ludwig's 31-day subathon back
in 2021 made him the most sub 2 twitch
streamer by the end of it we're about
there boys
there it is you were here this is the
new record on Twitch
for most subscribers all time
holy [__] that was insane but the
difference is that once again Kai came
in with a plan Ludwig's stream was an
uncapped sub Bonanza that ended up going
far longer than he initially intended
Kai on the other hand knew how long he
was going to be live for and what
content he would be making each day the
only thing he didn't know was how huge
it would get
30 seconds left crazy I'm crazy I'm a
psychopath no arms don't count what
what oh
what is that what is this
what kind of one you're gonna get
I just went like I just want science to
like spin the block like get out of here
get out of here get out of here
anybody trying to message me
dude
the question is is will Kai not beat my
record
but beat ludwigs oh my God
oh my God bro
[Music]
with the health and support of his
friends family and colleagues as well as
his loyal fan base Kai sonat passed the
300 000 subscriber Mark and officially
broke Ludwig's record Kai also became
the first black streamer to be crowned
the king of twitch I think my favorite
part of the summer time was like just
the experience but I was just seeing all
the all the ups and downs of it
all like the the momentum of it all like
Tina chat like going to its lowest and
then coming back up to His Highest
um and actually being able to say my
favorite holiday stuff without probably
be actually saying that I completed it
and I was able to do it and you know
just making just making history in Black
during Black History Month was crazy to
me anyone who was still somehow under
the impression that Kai was just a flash
in a pan was proven wrong once and for
all turns out he had Riz enough to charm
all of us and he did it all in his own
unique way okay so stop yelling bro bro
he just hit the sub record of course
he's gonna be yelling bro he got 300 000
Subs if you're getting 350 for that's a
million dollars you're telling me you
wouldn't be yelling if you just got a
million dollars I'd be yelling that'd be
great let's go guys kc3 man hey man make
sure y'all go over to uh Kai and
everything man uh congratulate him
non-stop bro and this
was only the beginning Kai won another
streamer of the Year award shortly after
his month-long broadcast ended and the
winner a best streamer of the whole
entire year is
I just want to say that I'm more ready
to work than ever you feel what I'm
saying I appreciate everybody who
supported me in any little big any type
of way any type of way I just want to
say um I love everybody you family hope
you guys are having a great night and uh
I'll see y'all soon yes sir and yet
despite being literally the biggest
streamer the platform had ever seen
which still didn't really recognize his
success we are so proud of you
Laura Anna and all of your friends at
twitch
Kai was understandably pretty confused
when twitch sent him sneakers after his
explosive sabathon many Kai included
expected to see an exclusive streaming
contract a reward for the attention he
brought to the platform instead he got
nothing they probably thought they were
really cool like the the sentiment
behind it obviously very tone deaf yeah
uh considering all the conversation
about Kai deserves like a bigger
contract they need to you know he's
already the king of twitch they need to
you know pay him like the king yeah the
heavy light it lays the crown you know
what I mean yeah at just 21 years old
Kai sanat didn't just reach the very top
of the streaming world he redefined what
the very top was his incredible rise
opened doors for an entirely new
generation of content creator but make
no mistake none of Kai's success was
accidental he worked his ass off planned
every step and was willing to make some
difficult personal decisions to get to
where he wanted to be and despite the
lack of recognition he still got to the
top no one can take away his
accomplishments and whatever comes next
it'll all be part of the plan we did it
we made history
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock